hey guys it's Jenna here right where do
I start
so I haven't been uploading any new
videos for the past month because I've
been on a digital detox oh my god come
here come here say hi to the camera
this is Marty
Rusty's new friend all right I want this
video to be a really honest video on why
I went on a digital detox how it has
sort of like shifted my life and what
are my plans for 2016 so for the past
month I've been away in the UK and also
I went travelling to Sweden usually
whenever I travel I will always bring my
laptop with me everywhere I go
because I want to know that you know I
would have the ability to access my
YouTube channel all my social media
platforms and you know I will be able to
constantly share new videos or what I'm
doing with you guys
so this was actually the first holiday
especially when I was in Sweden I
decided that you know what I'm not gonna
bring my laptop I'm gonna stay away from
my laptop and I actually went on a trip
where it doesn't allow me to have any
access to my mobile phone so when I was
at the UK I managed to catch up with a
lot of my friends people that has seen
me groan not just as a person but people
that saw how I started my channel and
grew my channel on YouTube and I've been
doing YouTube for the past almost three
years right now come this February it
will be three years one of my friends
asked me this really simple question
Johanna are you happy and it should just
be a really simple answer but I could
not answer that question I I couldn't
answer that I wasn't happy and I
say that I'm happy so my time away being
away from my work which is pretty much
everything is online and just giving
time back to myself to reflect on me as
an individual I realized that deep down
I wasn't fulfilled when I started my
channel I wanted to focus on three
aspects that are important in my life
so Fitness food and faith I feel that
for the past three years I have achieved
as share a lot with you guys in regards
to fitness and food
however the faith aspect is missing and
since coming back to Malaysia last year
I feel that I've been further away from
my self development and also being
mindful in what I do on a daily basis
so I told myself this year that I can't
keep going on this way I can't just say
that I can't complain because I want to
be happy a lot of people would they look
at my life they want to be in my
position because I'm blessed to be able
to turn my passion into my career
YouTube is something that I will be
doing for a really long time but this is
my platform this is my chance to share
what I love with you guys and also to
add value in other people's life and for
me to continue sharing my weekly videos
on YouTube I first have to reinvent
myself and shoes my life in the
direction that I want so I've taught
myself this year I want to focus on the
aspect of self-development and being
mindful in everything I do in my life
and everyday so every year what I will
do is write a list of things that I want
to accomplish and I have a really close
friend in London every year we would
write out lists and we would exchange it
and you know it is a really good way to
stay focused for the year and keep each
other accountable I want to share my
list with you guys because I hope that
my list will inspire you to keep growing
in your life and you know keep heading
towards the direction that you want in
your life so I have
things on my list this year and I've
broken it down to four main aspects
personal development YouTube stroke
Fitness travels which is something I'm
really passionate about and also me what
I want for myself okay
right so in regards to personal
development I want to start living a
more mindful life every day by first
doing my daily devotion so every morning
when I wake up I want to remind myself
to give gratitude and to meditate so the
second on my list is I want to pick up a
course and study again in the area of
mindfulness ideally I want to study for
my master's degree so hopefully that
will happen this year I just want to get
back into education and really just you
know take make a big shift in my life
and I feel that this is at the right
time for me to do that so guess if you
are interested in becoming a personal
trainer if you are interested in healthy
living and if you are passionate to help
others to get healthy not just from the
outside but from the inside I have been
working with the National Academy of
Sports Medicine to offer this
opportunity to you they are currently
offering a 14-day free trial to get all
my personal training costs so I would
recommend you to try it out and if you
feel that this is the direction that you
want to go down in your life then by all
means pick up at the full course link
and more information is in my
description box and the third on my list
is I want to also start a monthly blog
to share with you guys on my personal
development so this video in a way is my
first vlog on you know sharing that side
of me
basically to really emphasize a focus
more on the faith side as well so
hopefully you guys will gain some
insight and inspiration on my journey
and hopefully it will add value in your
life and in regards to youtube and
fitness I want to get back to uploading
weekly videos on my
okay at least one video a week I will
try my best to stick by that that is
your smarty playing with his toy and the
second - is I need to sort on my website
and keep it updated my website last year
was a mess it has been hacked so many
times no matter how much my web designer
kept trying to fix it it did not work
out so I really have to get us sorted
out and I want my website to be working
functioning so that I can provide you
with all the workout lists all the
recipes and also to share my travel
vlogs with you guys okay third I'm
looking at cutlery up with a
multi-channel network called makers and
I want to explore my opportunities with
them in regards to growing my brand not
just on YouTube but outside of YouTube
as well so that's on my list and next I
am looking and launching my own fitness
app to make my youtube videos more
accessible to you guys on the mobile
phone tablets you will get to follow my
workouts on the app and I want to keep
growing the number of subscribers and
this on my channel so that I can keep
reaching out to more people across the
globe I have been very blessed to be
given this platform and I want to try to
reach as many people as I can and just
add a little bit of inspiration in their
lives and your lives every day and the
next on my list is to always remind
myself that my audience which is you
guys is the core of my work you know
this platform would not exist without
you so I want to constantly engage with
you and try to help you in as many ways
as I can so if you have any feedbacks if
you have any video requests if you have
anything that you want to let me know
you know Eddie's life transformation
Body Transformation or even things that
inspire you feel free to write to me and
the next on my list is since being back
in Malaysia I want to establish my
presence more in Malaysia and also in
Singapore as a wellness and fitness
coach and most of you might already know
that I love traveling traveling to me
isn't just going on a nice holiday but
every time I travel I learn something
new about myself and it really gives me
the time and space to reflect on my life
because being away being in a different
country and being away from everything
you know then it's when I can really
look back and you know it just gives me
the time to really clear my mind and the
way I like to travel is to do active
things so for instance I recently went
to Sweden and did dog sledding and when
I travel I love to walk I would explore
the city or place by walking so this
year I told myself that I want to start
my active travels blog and also to share
it on my social media platform so that
you guys can see my active travels and I
want you to also share with me your
active travels you know Fitness doesn't
just have to be about working out it
doesn't just have to be in a juice
setting but everytime you travel it is
an opportunity for you to explore a
place and to stay active as well so
that's on my list and the second one is
again I want to go on at least one
adventurous holiday this year and third
I want to take my entire family on a
cruise I haven't been on a holiday with
my entire family for probably two years
now so I think it would be a nice thing
for it to just get away on a short
cruise and just really take the time to
bond and it will be nice and the fall of
my travel list is I want to go on at
least one spiritual retreat this year
hopefully on my birthday right
God is a mom this isn't it and the last
area I want to focus on is me so I
to continue to set aside 10% of my
earnings and use it to help others in a
positive way I have been doing that for
many years and I want to continue to set
aside 10% of my earnings and help others
I believe that when you're blessed with
things in your life or not just
financially it is your responsibility to
help others who are less fortunate than
you and to just you know give back to
the world around you and society so I
want to continue to do that and the
second of my list is I want to start
reading again I want to start reading at
least two books this year it's not a lot
but when you're so caught up with work
and when you're so you know caught up
with everything around you really can be
hard so the first book that I got myself
this year is by Marianne Williamson the
author of a return to love this book is
basically a daily devotion and
reflections so it has 365 days every day
it's just one page is sort of like a
daily devotion for you to read for me to
read and to you know just be inspired
and reflect and remind myself to be
mindful to be more loving and to be just
grateful for everything I have
so this is currently my daily devotional
book that I will be reading through this
year it's really short it's only you
know five minutes of devotion and
meditation every morning but it will
make a huge difference in the way you
live your life and the way you look at
things and the way you approach things
as well so I would recommend you to get
a daily devotion book it doesn't have to
be religious being mindful isn't about
religion being mindful is being aware of
your thoughts your emotions and your
action and once you learn to be more
mindful every day you will start to see
the changes and
in your life in a positive way the next
on my list is I want to continue to
improve on a strength and flexibility
and to remind myself and you guys to
have fun when I do my workouts ok and
next is I want to start to explore where
who is for the past year I felt really
really unsettled I decided to come back
to Malaysia because I feel the need to
be closer with my family and it is the
best decision that I've ever made but at
the same time I don't really feel
settled here I at this point in my life
I have to be honest I do not know where
home is so I want to keep exploring that
and keep that option open well then
that's on my list which is number 19 is
I hope to meet someone nice well at this
point in my life I am single there is
nothing wrong with being single it won't
be nice to meet someone nice someone
that I can talk to someone that I can
really have a deep conversation with and
some of the shares are the same value as
I do so you know what it is important to
write down what you want and then if s
it because that way the universe has its
way to bring it to you so I thought I
want to add it into my list and the
final thing on my list is to remember to
always give thanks in the morning and
ask myself at the end of the day what is
the highlight of my day no matter how
bad your day is if you take the moment
to reflect on the positive aspect in
your life you will start to have a shift
in your mind and things would just be
better so guys if you do not yet have a
list I
recommend you to take the time and write
down your list it is not difficult do
not think or overthink on what you want
to write down just take the time and
write down whatever that comes first to
your mind because those other things
that you really want to work on and want
to accomplish and I believe that when
you write down and you don't commit
yourself to this list you are more
likely to attract these things that you
want in your life and move towards the
direction that you want in your life
okay so let me know what's on your list
for 2016 and at the end of this year
when you look back at your list you will
find that you have accomplished a lot of
things on this list because you first
started by manifesting what you want
having this platform for me to reach out
to each and every one of you is the best
gift that I've received and I know that
this is my calling and I want to
continue to do that so you know I just
want to say how grateful I am for your
continuous love and support for what I
do and I hope that the way I live my
life will be will continue to be an
inspiration to you and you know in
return you will inspire others to live a
more healthy happier and balanced life
and this is what I want my channel to be
and this is what I want my life to be
thank you